what are you doing here Nicholas hasn't  been to school in almost a month  I wanted to ask how are you has  something happened you realize the  school is talking about expelling you  can I live with you  you said you don't feel very close to  people your age  your other son he needs you as well  and you're at work all of the time has  he been able to talk about the divorce  I've tried to be there for you I've  tried to give you strength what's going  on are you on drugs you can you can just  live your life doing whatever you feel  like  I don't know what's happening to me  I feel like a complete failure  I wasn't there fam  joy in our family we give these big  speeches about life and then you abandon  us I have the right to reinvent my life  hello son you came to tell me what a  good dad you are what do you want  Applause  it's my little boy  I can't give up on it  [Music]  foreign